our study looked at the evolution of
African climate over the last fifteen
thousand years what we discovered in
this sediment core was that this
transition from Africa being completely
vegetated roughly between five and ten
thousand years ago to the desert that it
is now that transition happened at
almost at exactly five thousand years
ago one of the purposes of this paper
was to explore this particular area that
we were looking at and bring together
evidence from other Lake records nearby
and and at least for the region that
we're considering and this is for the
for the Horn of Africa so Somalia
Ethiopia Kenya Tanzania and a little bit
further west as well for that whole
region we get a consistent story that
the end of the African humid period of
five thousand years ago occurred really
quickly within centuries we know what
causes the the overall transition from
Africa becoming or having been much
wetter in the past to the very dry North
Africa that exist today that's due to a
change in the Earth's orbit around the
Sun and that changes the amount of
sunlight that you get during a given
season let's a summer if we look through
geologic time and you sort of go back
through the eons there's just tons of
evidence that life responds to climate
there's no shortage of evidence that
organisms large and small from bacteria
to mammoth respond to climate in many
cases in the geologic past there are
examples of great extinctions or great
speciation events link to changes in
climate the most recent being at the end
of the Ice Age their so called the
megafauna extinction when all the woolly
mammoths and the sort of large
mammals disappeared from North America
so the sediment core that we collected
what was interesting about this
particular study is that this was a
penultimate leg of a cruise at
circumnavigated Africa so it started
near Morocco went toward South Africa
and then marched its way back up East
Africa the coast of East Africa and
fortunately we were on a dutch flag ship
because actually the timing of our
cruise was two months before nine eleven
at that time the Pirates hadn't gotten
so bold as we now know them to be they
weren't coming out hundreds of
kilometers away from the Mara from the
coastline as we were sailing along the
Somali coast which you know is known by
everyone as being a really terrible
place we had to shut off all the lights
all the navigation lights which is
normally totally illegal but we shut up
all navigation lights in all interior
lights and so all we had were those who
serve red photographers lights if you
know those was very dim red lights we
had that and we had total radio silence
which the captain wasn't particularly
happy about but I was certainly the safe
thing to do and then we had a whole
protocol for what to do if we were
boarded because we had women on board
and so one of the things that the
captain was really concerned about was
you know what might happen and so we had
this whole plan to lock certain people
up in the chain Locker and you know it
was really it was really pretty
nerve-wracking for a lot for a lot of
people the side story to this paper is
that we got a we developed this record
from a place where it's just impossible
to do science now and that's I think one
of the side stories who this whole
geopolitical conflict period is that
there's a whole section of the world
that we can't do science in and it's not
because the science isn't fascinating
and interesting it's just because it's
closed and what makes it doubly sad is
that the people of these countries that
are in these areas like in Yemen
and in Ethiopia that are so eager to be
part of the science there they're really
well trained they're really smart
they're there they know what the science
problems are they just can't do anything
because the place is off-limits it's in
such contested areas even work I used to
do in Kenya on land now they're areas
that I can't go to any more we were shot
out last time we were there so you have
to mean it's just it's it's like the
Wild West out there